ceon va faire être perdu au milieu des
démarches administratives Renaldo
connaît bien il y a 10 ans il a lancé
son entreprise de bâtiment au Portugal
aujourd'hui il souhaite installer une
filiale dans les ivelines avec deux de
ses salariés il est venu demander de
l'aide à la CCI en Portugal et en France
c'est la même chose la difficulté la
bureocratie c'est la même chose c'est
pour ça que je passé ici en CCI pour
faire plus rapide la chose plus de
rapidité et plus de sécurité c'est
l'objectif du nouveau dispositif
securitact mis en place par le centre de
formalité des entreprises ici on suit un
projet de sa création jusqu'au 3 ans de
la société pourquoi c'est 3 ans parce
que les statistiques montrent que
pratiquement trois entreprises sur 5 ne
tiennent pas 3 ans ça peut être
éventuellement un projet au moment de
l'immatriculation qui a mal été
formalisé mais c'est aussi un projet qui
s'est mal développé donc cet
accompagnement logiquement au bout de 3
ans vous êtes en mesure d'avoir une une
entreprise pérenne l'Étap la plus
importante dans la création d'entreprise
c'est choisir et formaliser ses statuts
c'est là que le dispositif securitact
intervient le service coûte 450 € hors
taxe aux entrepreneurs c'est finalement
une formule clé en main que l'on propose
à nos porteurs de projet qui
consiste à trois rendez-vous successifs
qui peuvent être réalisés assez
rapidement en 72
he et on va créer une entreprise
sécurisée par un de nos experts en droit
fiscal et social et procéder tout le
suivi de l'immatriculation du cadre
supérieur aux commerçants ambulants le
CFE accueille tous les profils plus de
500 entrepreneurs passent les portes de
ce centre chaque mois ok ok c'est bon
allez on y va impeccable